he was on my just getting started
podcast he has not one but two podcasts
he's got the rex chapman show with mr
josh hopkins who's been on this program
uh and also uh a terrific new podcast as
well called
charges um his guest this week is
somebody who you love chris i know for
with your boston college days right and
your boston uh upbringing you're doing
an upbringing chris herron is his
is his guest and now he's our guest once
again rex
chapman back here on the rich eisen show
how are you rex hey rich how are you
doing today buddy better for talking to
you sir
better for talking about always always
always fun
so let's get into uh the the playoffs
right now what's your
impression of what we've seen so far uh
we're coming up uh tomorrow will be the
uh
the end of the first week of the
playoffs tonight i guess technically as
well what what do you take what's your
takeaway
so far well uh you know i've got a
soft spot for the phoenix sun yep and um
an unbelievable year second seed only
one of two teams in the league to win
50 games and get rewarded by playing the
los
angeles wakers in the first round of the
seventh seat so
down 2-1 chris paul a little banged up
hopefully the suns will bounce back in
game four
um but yeah i really like what
brooklyn's doing of course how can you
not like that right now milwaukee's very
workmanlike denver denver portland is a
series i'm keeping an eye on i
i like portland in that series why do
you like them
what do you what do you think about i
mean i is i guess is austin rivers an
anomaly the way that he finished him off
last night with uh with joe kitchen
uh no no i think i i'm really enjoying i
really am i was with melo for
some of his career out in denver and i'm
i'm so thrilled to watch carmelo he
really has
taking a step back and he doesn't have
to be the guy anymore he's playing
his effort is great defensively his
body's terrific
and then you know they got damon cj i
just think they're going to wear them
down
i think murray being out is just too
much to overcome so what it what
what is the uh i guess fix for phoenix
right now what do you think monty
williams is thinking he does have a
banged up chris paul
he's got a budding star in ayton however
you've got two one of the greatest
double
you know headed monsters the nba has
ever put out on a floor
in lebron aging like the fine wine that
he is
and anthony davis being in the prime of
his career and you know
i know you watched him anthony davis
from the very beginning of his
playing career at kentucky so what what
is monty williams thinking right now
do you think rex well you know i think
he's he's got to hope that
the the next couple days do do chris uh
paul some rest his rest uh really
benefits him
hopefully he can continue to get
treatment and get a little bit better i
think there
it's an uphill battle if he's not
himself uh
and then you know i remember i played
eight years
uh seven years in the nba before ever
making playoffs
and we finally make it the year i went
to
miami we were 41 and 41 sneaked into the
playoffs
and had the good fortune to play the 72
and 10 73 and 72 and 10 chicago bulls
and they swept us like a jv team in
three games
um devin book i say this because it's
devin booker he's
what his fifth year now first chance at
the playoffs
and it's different you know he went out
and did what he did on
in game one and he's kind of struggled
since but the playoffs are different
it's officiated different and when you
come up come across two just elite guys
like lebron and a.d and you're playing
those guys as young guys deandre ayton
and devin booker
it's maddening because you feel like
they get every damn call
so you know these guys phoenix is up
against it but they just have to get one
and take that series back to phoenix why
is it done why is it different
walk me through that i mean you know i
think that
um well
it's like i remember guarding reggie
miller regarding reggie before he became
an all-star
and after he became an all-star once he
became an all-star he got every call
every
every he'd just run into you and flop
and he'd get the call
and he knew what he was doing um but it
officials too they're human and they get
influenced by
by crowds um
it's just one of those things uh the i i
will say this
those guys have earned the right to get
a call here or there
no i know and chris paul i don't know if
you heard his post game comment last
night he he mentioned three times
uh 11 in a row that's what he said 11 in
a row and if
case anybody was wondering that's the
number of losses in a row
he's had in a game that's been
officiated by scott foster
and he even said the words if you were a
betting man i mean he went out basically
and and and damn near connected dots to
something the nba certainly doesn't want
you know in the mind's eye of a fan uh
was that frustration
walk me through the mindset of a player
like like cp3 to say something i think
it's
yeah i think it's frustration uh of
course but
you know there are guys that you just i
remember scott foster threw me out of
the game i
accidentally poked him in the eye
arguing a call
and got suspended but uh yeah
you know i'm anxious to see how the
league
responds to what chris had to say um
i i can't imagine that we'll go uh
unpunished but we'll see yeah some guys
just don't like
certain play some players don't like
certain referees and i'm sure there are
referees that don't like certain players
so you got the gate because you
accidentally poked scott foster in the
eye while arguing a call with him is
that what you're saying
well rasheed wallace ran over me in
portland
a clear i don't know if you've ever
heard of block charges
but a clear charge yes and
a clear charge and i stood up
he caught a block and i went right up
got in his face and
pointed and accidentally poked him right
in the eye
and that was the end of rex chapman for
that game see you you were in the
showers
get out of here that was it went back
while we're hitting the wayback machine
what was it like uh well you said it was
your first playoff experience and
there's jordan who you obviously had
you know knew and had a history with and
you know
you have some great stories about that
you told a story in my podcast of him
rolling a bowling ball backwards to
try and uh clear a lane um right so
he palmed it so you've been around what
was that like
to be out there on the floor against the
last dance bulls like that
well i again i had played against those
guys yeah for
six or seven years and
it wasn't and had some success here and
there
it wasn't until i played them in that
playoff series
that i got to see what
those i wasn't on very good teams they
didn't have to be engaged to get to beat
my teams we weren't playing them in the
playoffs
but when i saw those guys in the
playoffs and saw how engaged they were
it it gave me a way better appreciation
for you know the teams that were really
doing battle with those guys the knicks
and um you know those teams from back in
detroit because michael and scotty
and that squad were so damn good
and when they were engaged they were
down there unbeatable
and then the next year you're on phoenix
and you're you know teammates with jason
kidd and
kj and you're going against let me make
sure i get this right you're going
against the camp
that left shrimp sam perkins gary payton
seattle sonics and you you dropped 42 in
a
the first game in that series to get the
first one um
in that game in that series rex what was
was the was the
rim as large as the ocean that night for
you in seattle
well yeah but it also helps when uh
a team can uh let you run free because
you've got jason kidd and kevin johnson
on your team
they couldn't pay too much attention to
me if those guys would have crushed them
so uh i was the beneficiary of playing
with
hall of fame type players and you know
steve nash was on that team also oh
he had a dnp that night i'm looking in
the statue
he didn't play much that year what do
you think his challenge is right now rex
what what's his challenge right now uh
with a team that's
um that's up 2-0 everybody's pretty much
putting them in sharpie against the
bucks right now
for a second round match-up that is
going to be just lit
what what is what is nash's challenge
right now your former teammates
rex yeah knowing stevie like i do
he's the ultimate competitor and
he's got a very unique team of
personalities
and i think that his biggest challenge
is is what to let go you know
i think he probably wants to call a
timeout every play down the court
but there are things he just has to let
go with this team
and i think that mike mike d'antoni
being there with him
in his first year coaching is a real
it's a real positive of course mike
has history with james coaching james
and houston
but that that team is good they're
really good and if they fight if they
if they find a way to keep defending
at you know an elite level they're going
to be awfully tough
rex chapman here on the rich eisen show
let's talk about your pod chargers
uh i'm going to give you the floor on
why you you created it and the people
you've been interviewing
for fascinated me right and it's so much
yeah it's so much fun just
uh this is a little bit different pod
it's just me
interviewing you know other people
who've gotten in trouble um
you know maybe with the law maybe just
in the court of public opinion
you know being people who played sports
and
and have gotten in some kind of some
kind of mess
and i'm enjoying talking to them about
what it was like at that
just terrible moment for them you know
we know what it was like from the
outside looking in
i'm enjoying finding out what it was
like for them you know i've interviewed
metta uh sanford art test ron artest
meta world peace that guy
ryan leaf chris herron um
just did jim larritz recently bonzi
wells
i got doc goodin coming up so many more
i'm really excited the best part about
it is
for me it's kind of cathartic you know
because you sit there and
yeah everybody's all of us in sports
have been asked the same old sports
questions over and over
right but i've been really really
heartened by the willingness of these
people coming on to open up
and really just lay it all out there and
uh i'm enjoying
it and i think so far the listeners are
enjoying well i'm certainly the dwight
good in conversation i can't wait to
hear that rex
i mean right right i mean for sure what
was
i'm a fan well i mean it's not just that
too but i mean
what what truly also could have been and
how great he was despite
you know uh his struggles is um
it's remarkable i i mean it really is
certainly in the the city of new york
where we're agreeing for both teams
what'd you learn from chris herron
what'd you get from him uh you know i i
i think i had i have so many friends
who are friends with chris he and i
don't really know one another
but within just minutes of sitting down
because you know he's friends with jason
kidd and
steve nash who i've known for 30 years
now
it was almost like you know we just
picked right up
it was very comfortable uh you know
the the thing that i didn't know i
really didn't and i didn't watch his 30
for 30 my son told me to
a while back but i figured it was going
to be sad and i hope
i don't do well with that so i did watch
it
before he and i talked and i just bawled
i bawled my eyes out the thing that i
didn't know
i didn't know chris is he really
took a turn for the worse when he went
to oxycontin
that's you know essentially what
happened to me
and i had no idea that's what you know
sort of triggered his
foray into heroin so i really learned
something on that just from a
you know a standpoint and i should know
these things
i should have known that but uh yeah i
just and hearing the guys here hearing
the people
uh you know shoot i've cried a couple
times on here i've almost cried several
times and
and i've had a couple of guests here up
um this stuff's hard to talk about but
again i think it's cathartic and
i think it can help people out there
we're all struggling
uh somebody knows someone who's
struggling no question about it and
that's the charges with rex chapman
podcast and then of course you know may
has
been mental health awareness month we're
coming towards the end of may and a
fascinating conversation i don't know if
you're
paying much attention to it but you are
definitely active on twitter so i'm sure
it has crossed your
your twitter timeline about naomi osaka
at the french open
saying that she will not have any uh
any any press conference appearances
with the the media while at the french
open citing her
mental health saying that um having
conversations with people who doubt her
and ask her questions over and over
again um
is not um helpful and that some
journalists kick
kicking a person while they're down is
something that she will not
take part in um i wonder what you think
of all that
rex good for
her i mean look i know it's
it's dicey you know she's playing tennis
people want to ask
questions um you know the media and
and athletes entertainers we do work
together you know
we do so i get that it's it's difficult
for some people but this is a young lady
who's you know coming up in a i can't
imagine rich i was talking to someone
yesterday
i can't imagine being a professional
athlete or
even a college athlete in today's world
with social media
i i can't i don't know how these how
these athletes do it so
good for her you know maybe this won't
be a forever type thing but
i'm i'm happy for her i wish that more
more people could be understanding
of you know what young people are going
through and she's trying look she's
trying to do something extremely
daunting
and it takes more than just the physical
so good for her
so what what do you mean that uh social
media because you're seeing what people
are saying
uh in real time you know because twitter
does allow
uh the popcorn throwers um
the ability to you know some somebody
may be screaming something horrible
like uh john yamarans uh john marant's
parents apparently father definitely was
talking about that you know
and and you know morant may not hear it
because
those fans are so far away but on the
phone you can see it
you can get it you know if you're
thumbing through it is that what you're
referring to
pretty much right yes i think that
i think it's hard you know look
everybody wants to
wants to be loved and everyone everybody
wants to see
nice things written about them when we
were when i was growing up you didn't
have any of that
what was written in the paper that's all
that was said what you said on in
interviews that's all it was said
there's so much commentary out there now
some of it's great and some of it's you
know spot on some of it's great
reporting on
most of it is garbage and trying to
filter that out as a young athlete
and you know focus on this is something
i should pay attention to this is
something i shouldn't pay attention to
i can't imagine trying to negotiate that
while you know trying to be the best at
what you're what you're doing
rex you're the best man uh look for my
call as uh
we get our way into the second round of
the playoffs and certainly you know your
your teammate as you refer to as stevie
nash i mean he has
he is in a launch position to say the
least
and and the bucks look like they're
gonna that's gonna be the team that
might come in off of a sweep the sixers
versus
you know nixon hawks um winner that
looks
like a lot of fun and it sure looks like
lebron and
and a.d are gonna be the the nightmare
seven seed that nobody ever wants to see
again
sure looks like it you know it looks
that way but hey
you know let's talk again here in the
next week or two and
and catch up do some more nba playoffs
let's do it let's do it thanks for the
call rex everybody can go get
your uh podcast we're all podcasts
required with mr josh hopkins the rex
chapman show and charges
with rex chapman you're the best man
thanks thanks rich much love buddy right
back at you that's rex chapman
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here